economía en directo américa de france 24
ya está conmigo en el estudio daniela
blandón dani bienvenida feliz lunes
iniciamos semana hablando de economía en
honduras que podemos decir de la
economía de ese país centroamericano que
llega de un fin de semana electoral pero
que si raúl muy buenos días espero que
haya descansado todo el fin de semana
como lo hice yo bueno yo descanse el
domingo pero no fue muy buena idea
porque tengo un dolor de espalda tanto
descansar daniela bueno yo creo que sí
ahora sí vamos para honduras porque
todavía no sabemos con certeza quién
gana las elecciones en este país lo que
sí sabemos es cuál es la economía que va
a recibir y es que después de 40 años de
retorno a la democracia y de 10
elecciones generales los hondureños no
han visto grandes cambios en su frágil
economía veamos es un país de más de 9
millones de habitantes que hace 40 años
la pobreza afectaba al 60 por ciento de
la población y hoy más del 70 por ciento
de los hondureños son considerados
pobres el desempleo al cierre de 2020
por su parte estaba a punto de tocar los
2 y el doble de un año atrás cuando la
tasa de desocupación era de poco más del
5% esto desde luego debido a la pandemia
y el producto interno bruto se contrajo
89 % en 2020 por causa también del
coronavirus mientras que el año pasado o
el año inmediatamente anterior 2019
había crecido un 26 por ciento danny y
que decir entonces las remesas de las
que depende este país bueno hay una
buena noticia en medio de todo y es que
en lo que se ha beneficiado la crisis al
país centroamericano es en las remesas
que representan un 20 por ciento de su
producto interno bruto éstas provienen
principalmente de eeuu con más del 93
por ciento pero también de dos países
como españa canadá y panamá con pequeñas
cantidades en 2020 los envíos desde el
exterior sumaron más de 5 mil 700
millones de dólares eso fue un 3,9 por
ciento más que en 2019 pero este año
raúl todo está mejorando inclusive en
este tema de las remesas porque hasta
julio ya iban creciendo en más del 30
y lo que parece que no está mejorando es
la inflación en españa que está en su
nivel más alto en tres décadas sin su
segundo país raúl y de en noviembre los
precios aumentaron 59 por ciento frente
a noviembre del año pasado este es su
ritmo de crecimiento más elevado desde
1992 y se explica principalmente por el
alza de los precios de los alimentos y
también de los carburantes la inflación
empezó a subir a principios de año en
españa como en el resto de la unión
europea después de haber permanecido en
negativo durante la mayor parte de 2020
y en noviembre sube inclusive más de lo
que lo hace el bloque comunitario en su
conjunto bueno ya saben los que usted
amaneció descansada ya con dolor de
espalda y ahora le pregunta entonces
cómo amanecieron hoy libre en los
mercados después del desplome que vimos
el viernes bueno las bolsas están mixtas
hay más optimismo en europa que en hacia
todo sobre esta esta nueva variante del
virus del hobbit 19 pues la bolsa de
tokio por ejemplo cerró este lunes con
un descenso del 1 63 por ciento
principal indicador japón decidió volver
a endurecer sus medidas fronterizas y
eso alertó a los inversionistas ahora si
nos vamos a europa por el contrario los
mercados si están rebotando después de
las grandes pérdidas del viernes que
oscilaron entre el 2 y el 5 por ciento
la bolsa de pared cayó más del 5% el
viernes pues hoy londres parís y madrid
suben más del 1 por ciento a medida o a
media jornada mejor de este lunes y que
se espera eso ya hablamos entonces de
europeas ya pero que se espera para esta
apertura de wall suite claro porque wall
street' ahora abre en unas horas y pues
las operaciones por el mercado de la
bolsa de nueva york- están positivas
después de un verdadero viernes negro
bursátil los tres principales índices de
la bolsa de nueva york cerraron con
pérdidas superiores al 2 por ciento como
vemos en el gráfico esto el viernes
esperando desde luego pues qué es lo que
va a pasar hoy también los precios del
petróleo están recuperándose alrededor
del 5 por ciento después de haber
retrocedido más del 10 por ciento el
viernes cuando registraron su peor caída
en un día desde abril de 2020
cuesta hoy cerca de 75 dólares y para
finalizar dani que nos tiene como cifra
el día a colombianos vamos porque cuatro
mil ocho pesos cuesta un dólar en este
país es el precio más alto de la divisa
estadounidense desde el 29 de abril de
2020 cuando estaba iniciando la pandemia
ahora le digo hay personas que se
benefician de este valor del dólar y
entre ellos están los productores de
café petróleo y otros commodities como
el carbón además de quienes reciben
remesas también pero hay perdedores
también los industriales que tienen que
importar insumos y también el mismo
gobierno que tiene que pagar su deuda
externa en dólares y como yo que me voy
de vacaciones de vacaciones para mexico
perdedor dios mío le he prestado un
poquito de dinero usted àngel a ver si
me ayuda con esas vacaciones gracias al
y nos vemos más adelante entonces con
más economía ahora vamos a ver nuestro
reportaje